hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this year wrapped up the sixth annual
Google i/o 2013 conference in San
Francisco California there are a lot of
awesome things that happens and also a
lot of memorable things that didn't
happen that we expected to happen but if
you don't want to watch the three
hour-long keynote which I'll include
below the like button and if you want to
watch the dozens of other hours of
sessions this video while it might be a
little bit long is a condensed version
of that and without no further ado we're
gonna go ahead and give you the top ten
announcements from Google i/o 2013
alright Koki get it off at number 10 was
Android studio now this is a developer
conference so we got a respect that
there are a lot of developers there and
one of the things they showed off called
Android studio was a really impressive
sort of console looking thing that
allows developers to better manage
rendering the size of their applications
for basically different screen sizes and
different layouts in order to abide by
androids design guidelines and it
actually looked like a pretty cool thing
that'll help us see a lot more quality
apps in the Play Store number 9 is
notification sync across devices so
maybe you have the same app installed on
more than one device they'll now be able
to take advantage of this API I swipe to
dismiss an application in maybe an app
called whatsapp on my tablet and my
phone will no longer display that
notification either so if I have a whole
conversation in some messaging app on
one device and I pick up the other one I
don't want that notification anymore so
now that's built in number eight is
improvements to Google Chrome a lot of
people don't know not only is Android
the most popular mobile platform but
chrome is the most popular browser
period so a lot of improvements went
into chrome on both the desktop and
mobile and the coolest thing about that
what they showed was a demo of this
racing game that spanned across multiple
devices so they connected all the
devices together both iOS and Android
devices alike and each device had a
player and you touch your screen to
control your race car across everyone
else's device which is really cool the
video moved from device to device the
sound of your race car moved from device
to device it was really cool and was all
going through Google Chrome something
that people are probably never going to
use but definitely an awesome demo
worthy feature anyway number seven is
the Google Play Music service it's now
called Google Play Music all access
which is a bit of a mouthful but I'll
just keep calling in google music for
now but it's a subscription music
service so this puts Spotify on watch
for $9.99 a month you get unlimited
access to all the songs in Google Play
and including the ones you already
uploaded of course and if you sign up
before June 30 if you actually get it
for $7.99 a month and you get a free
30-day trial the service itself looks to
be pretty awesome and it might still be
us only which is really unfortunate
because Google has a habit of not making
their services internationally available
but nevertheless it's pretty cool and
the app itself is also really really
good I've been using the app for the
past couple of days and I'm going on a
trip
very soon while I'll be using the app on
an airplane so I'm making some playlists
and everything like that
but it's very smooth very fluid it
allows you the ability to create a radio
station based off of a specific song or
playlist and it just creates an endless
playlist of songs for you and you can
control the order of the queue and
everything but you know endless music
discovery that's really what it should
be all about so Spotify like I said is
on notice because Google Play Music all
access has arrived number six is the new
Google Plus now a lot of people say no
one uses Google Plus and that's fine if
you think that but Google Plus whether
you like it or not is becoming a huge
part of tying all the different services
that Google has together so your account
whether you post things or share things
or not is pretty critical and it's
gotten a whole UI refreshed a whole
redesign a very neat to multiple column
cards layout on the desktops now you
won't really be able to say you know it
looks different on the desktop from the
phone from the tablet now they all look
the same and that multiple column UI and
it also looks really good you get that
holo font to get some nice animations
you get some smooth scrolling you get a
whole bunch of different smart features
where if you automatically upload an
album of photos as you go around on
vacation it automatically uploads them
all in full resolution and you get to
automatically enhance them and tag your
friends faces in them and it'll combine
things together and make panoramas when
it notices you have certain pictures and
it'll automatically take the best photos
that are in focus and when people are
smiling and the sharpest best contrast
once it's very very smart with your
photos and gives you a basic highlight
reel of all the best photos you took so
maybe you took six hundred photos on one
trip it'll give you a highlight reel of
the best 50 of them based on what it
thinks were awesome
so that's pretty cool and like I said
there are some neat automatic features
like automatic hashtags so if you take a
picture of say the Eiffel Tower it'll
automatically add the hashtag Eiffel
Tower to your post so you can discover
more posts that have that same thing in
them so if you visit some cool landmarks
you'll be able to see stuff like that
very cool stuff Google+ has some awesome
behind-the-scenes improvements using
Google's knowledge graph of course
number five is Google Play games Google
Play gaming is brand new it's basically
really gaming focused in the Play Store
and it uses app data sync across devices
to make it happen now the live demo on
stage didn't really work so well but
basically this app data sync will allow
you to have the same data inside every
application across devices perfect
example let's say
have Angry Birds on my tablet and on my
phone I get to level 30 of Angry Birds
on my phone and I want to put it down
and move over to the tablet I install it
on my tablet and I'm already on level 31
that's how it works you basically get
the same achievements and the same
unlock everything you had on one app on
one device we'll move to that same app
on a different device there are also
achievements and leaderboards among your
google+ friends and there's also
multiplayer so what's really cool is you
could have three different people
running you know an iPhone and iPad and
a nexus 10 and they could all race
against each other and like nudge the
person who's playing their iPad by
nudging their car on your screen and
they'll be able to see you nudge their
car on their iPad it's really cool the
multiplayer gaming looks very very neat
and there's a lot of games they're gonna
support that in the coming months so
that's really neat so Google Play games
number five pretty solid up like upgrade
I'd like where it's going even though
I'm not a big gamer on mobile I'll
probably be gaming more because of this
service number for hangouts it's a
multi-platform messaging service you'll
get it on the web you'll get it in iOS
so get it in Android it's almost
everywhere and now this was a very
confusing announcement because at first
we didn't know if it was replacing
certain things or if it was just being
added to the list of messaging services
Google has but basically over the next
couple months it'll be slowly eating up
and bringing into itself other Google
messaging services so right now the
Android app will just replace Google
Talk and once you get it working it'll
basically start the ability to have
multi person comment threads and just
hang out with people with text and with
video and emojis and all sorts of crazy
stuff and the app is very fast it's very
fluid I've been using it on Android and
it's really useful right now there is no
SMS support but we've seen a variety of
opinions on whether or not this will
actually happen I really hope it does
because if it does I'm messages in big
trouble but the bottom line is hangouts
is now a thing I had a separate
explaining video on Google babble
explained Google babble was its codename
when it was being developed by Google so
now that it's a real thing you can check
out that video and basically get the
gist of everything about Google's
hangouts app number three is Google now
improvements now Google now is one of
the biggest selling points of Android
it's one of the most awesome things in
the Play Store now it's on iOS and now
it's also in Chrome and a lot of the
improvements
first of all you get some new neat cards
where you can have reminders and certain
voice commands and things work a lot
better and some additional features but
also in Chrome it got really neat so
basically once the Google now experience
comes to Chrome you'll be able to just
go to google.com and say ok Google how
tall is Barack Obama and it'll give you
the same response that it would in
Google now for Android so they did a
bunch of neat demos and basically it's
now more contextually aware so you can
have almost a very conversation like
thing with it so for example I could say
how much does it cost to ride this
roller coaster in this park and it will
tell me that and then I can say how long
will it take to get there from here and
you didn't have to name it again when
you say there and here it knows you're
talking about the roller coaster in the
amusement park and when you say here it
knows you're talking about your current
location so it could tell you this
information without you repeating
yourself over and over again very cool
stuff
Google now improvements are definitely
gonna be a big help number two the
Samsung Galaxy s4 with Android 4.2 pure
jellybean on and this one caught us
totally by surprise is basically a super
Nexus I did a separate video on that not
too long ago so if you haven't already
seen it definitely click the annotation
there or if you can't there's a link
below of that like button but basically
now there is a galaxy s4 out there in
the Play Store it'll be available soon
with the pure nexus experience on it
straight from Google well I didn't know
that Samsung had any reason to do this I
didn't know that Google had any reason
to do this but now it is officially a
thing and yeah it's gonna be delivered
through the Play Store you'll be able to
get this unlocked with an unlocked
bootloader with the same bands as the
Nexus 4 on AT&T and t-mobile and you
also have LTE support which solves a lot
of the complaints that were about the
Nexus 4 you also get microSD card slot a
removable battery is basically a really
really great nexus experience and that
galaxy s4 and number one at Google i/o
2013 was the new Google Maps experience
this I felt was one of the most
overarching awesome improvements of
anything we saw a Google i/o I think it
was one of the most underrated things a
lot of people might be talking about
Google Maps as if it's it's pretty neat
but it's not all of that but it's
awesome
Google Maps had a huge amount of
improvements this year first of all that
new design
came to the iOS app that a lot of us
Android users were wondering why we
didn't get now we're going to be getting
that so there's going to be an update
for Google Maps for Android and there's
also a new Google Maps for desktop so
when you visit it on the web and you go
to Google Chrome or whatever browser you
use and open up Google Maps it's going
to be nuts the experience in Google Maps
is totally overhauled the search
interface is now changed so it gets
better travel instructions better more
intuitive clicking four locations and
everything like that you get a much
faster experience so zooming in and out
and navigating streets it's all very
very smart so if you click on a new
location it'll start to highlight the
streets between your location and that
new location it's really really smart
also click on locations we'll give you
built in card UI so you'll get Google
Offers built in and it's also basically
merged in with Google Earth so if you
keep zooming all the way in who get to
Google Street View and you'll be able to
just look at buildings in Google Street
view zoom slowly out you'll get to an
overhead view and satellite view and you
can keep zooming out and at the demo
they zoomed all the way out and zoomed
out to the full earth floating around
the solar system and they pointed out
that the clouds were actually being
rendered in real-time in that earth
which was really awesome very impressive
they even kept zooming out and showed
the earth in a relative position to the
moon and the Sun and the stars in the
sky awesome stuff definitely very cool
so the whole Google Maps experience is
totally revamped there's even a new
tablet app and tablet experience there's
an explorer button so you can explore
new places based on reviews there's a
new review system which is that a 5.0
star is integrated with Google+ and
Zagat there's a ton a ton of Google+
improvements and that's I think easily
one of the most underrated and awesome
things that happen at Google Plus Google
i/o so yeah there you go
a lot of stuff happened at Google i/o
2013 and I'm sure a lot more will be
unveiled over the coming days weeks and
months a lot of the things people were
asking were wait a second usually at
Google i/o we see a new version of
Android that didn't happen and I'm also
expecting that we will see Android 4.3
or maybe even four point two point three
jelly bean in the coming months number
two whereas the next Nexus 7 I also
think we're gonna see that soon in the
next coming months perhaps later in the
summer we're gonna see a 1080p Nexus
an updated version of that and there are
a lot of other questions about things
that also happen during the event and
I'll include as much information as I
can in the description below so that's
gonna be a goldmine of links and quotes
basically but yeah a lot of great stuff
happened definitely this year and I'm
looking forward to the next couple of
months and seeing the way things pan out
because not everything is fully baked
yet like I said Google Hangouts could
really use SMS support and a couple of
other things could really use some fine
tuning and tweaking but other than that
yeah that's it
top 10 things from Google i/o 2013 the
entire day 1 keynote began with a whole
spiel about how successful Google's been
and how much they're working with
developers to include them in further
projects and stuff like Google glass and
stuff and how there's been 900 million
Android activations but I think the best
part of Google i/o was the last part of
the day one key know where Google Larry
Page came out on stage and gave
basically a speech about how the future
looks for Google for himself for what he
thinks of the tech industry and it was
very fitting he kind of gave that speech
in front of the floating Google Earth in
the background so he was kind of talking
about how it feels about the whole world
as the globe spun behind him it was very
cool and the whole speech was really
really great so if you do have a chance
to watch what he says during that speech
before his Q&A which is also very unique
there's a link below to that the whole
keynote is on YouTube and you can check
out that as well so either way that's
been it that's been Google i/o 2013 wrap
up slash highlight slash summary video
definitely feel free to give a thumbs up
if you enjoyed and I will talk to you
guys in the very next video thanks for
watching guys hey